[Music]
juana ramirez de azbahe
sat before a panel of prestigious
theologians jurists
and mathematicians the viceroy of new
spain had invited them to test the young
woman's knowledge
by posing the most difficult questions
they could muster
but juana successfully answered every
challenge from complicated equations
to philosophical queries observers would
later liken the scene
to a royal galleon fending off a few
canoes
the woman who faced this interrogation
was born in the mid-17th century
at that time mexico had been a spanish
colony for over a century
leading to a complex and stratified
class system
juana's maternal grandparents were born
in spain making them members of mexico's
most esteemed class
but juana was born out of wedlock and
her father a spanish military captain
left her mother dona isabel to raise
wanna and her sisters alone
fortunately her grandfather's moderate
means ensured the family a comfortable
existence
and dona isabel set a strong example for
her daughters
successfully managing one of her
father's two estates despite her
literacy
and the misogyny of the time it was
perhaps
this precedent that inspired juana's
lifelong confidence
at age three she secretly followed her
older sister to school
when she later learned that higher
education was open only to men
she begged her mother to let her attend
in disguise
her request denied wanna found solace in
her grandfather's private library
by early adolescence she had mastered
philosophical debate
latin and the aztec language nawat
juana's precocious intellect attracted
attention from the royal court in mexico
city
and when she was 16 the viceroy and his
wife
took her in as their lady in waiting
here
her plays and poems alternately dazzled
and outraged the court
her provocative poem foolish men
infamously criticized
sexist double standards decrying how men
corrupt women
while blaming them for immorality
despite its controversy
her work still inspired adoration and
numerous proposals
but wanna was more interested in
knowledge than marriage
and in the patriarchal society of the
time there was only one place
she could find it the church while still
under the zealous influence of the
spanish inquisition
would allow wana to retain her
independence and respectability
while remaining unmarried at age 20 she
entered the hieronymite convent of santa
paula
and took on her new name sorhuana inez
de la cruz
for years sorghuana was considered a
prized treasure of the church
she wrote dramas comedies and treatises
on philosophy and mathematics
in addition to religious music and
poetry she accrued a massive library
and was visited by many prominent
scholars while serving as the convents
treasurer and archivist
she also protected the livelihoods of
her niece and sisters
from men who tried to exploit them but
her outspokenness
ultimately brought her into conflict
with her benefactors
in 1690 a bishop published sorwana's
private critique
of a respected sermon in the publication
he admonished
sorhana to devote herself to prayer
rather than debate
she replied that god would not have
given women intellect if he did not want
them to use it
the exchange caught the attention of the
conservative archbishop of mexico
slowly sorhana was stripped of her
prestige
forced to sell her books and give up
writing
furious at this censorship but unwilling
to leave the church
she bitterly renewed her vows in her
last act of defiance
she signed them i the worst of all
in her own blood deprived of scholarship
sorhana threw herself into charity work
and in 1695
she died of an illness she contracted
while nursing her sisters
today sarwana has been recognized as the
first feminist in the americas
she's the subject of countless
documentaries novels
and operas and appears on mexico's
200-peso banknote
in the words of nobel laureate octavio
paz
it is not enough to say that sorhwana's
work is a product of history
we must add that history is also a
product of her work
check out these lessons to learn about
other revolutionary women making good
trouble
in changing the course of history
[Music]
you